Avatar's Pandora is the wildest most
beautiful and most deadly place in the
galaxy
I mean who wouldn't want to live here
but how could the air kill you
what elements could make your body glow
and how could a gas giant destroy
Pandora's surface
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lived on Pandora
welcome to Pandora
located in the Alpha Centauri star
system this world is shrouded in mystery
and the Cinematic rules created by James
Cameron
for starters Pandora isn't even a planet
it's a moon of a gas giant just like our
Jupiter if this deadly Moon existed in
real life it would have to follow the
laws of physics and that's good news for
you because on Pandora you'd weigh 20
percent less than you do on Earth
take advantage of that weaker gravity
and leap across the Untamed alien jungle
but under no circumstances should you
ever jump in this water
the gas giant Pandora revolves around is
called polyphemus this massive planet is
only a bit smaller than Jupiter but it's
big enough to destroy all life on the
world you just arrived on
Pandora and polyphemus are tidally
locked so only one side of this moon is
always facing its gas giant
and that's dangerous because it could
cause tidal heating when one side gets a
slightly larger gravitational pull than
the other
sure this could create floating
mountains along the magnetic waves of
polyphemus except Pandora's surface
wouldn't be anything like it is in the
movie
in reality it would look more like
Jupiter's moon IO which also happens to
be the most volcanically active world in
the solar system
and if that wasn't enough Pandora's Sky
would be Radioactive
well sort of
if the magnetosphere of polyphemus was
just as big as Jupiter's Pandora would
be trapped within it
there it would be bombarded with charged
particles from its own star system
if Pandora didn't have its magnetosphere
you'd have no buffer from these intense
Rays so you'd better wear a what if
approved protection suit and trust us
you would want to have this suit because
he even if it wasn't radioactive the
atmosphere would still kill you
on Pandora the air would be mostly made
up of carbon dioxide and Xenon both of
these gases in high concentration would
instantly suffocate you
oh and that rotten smell yeah that's
hydrogen sulfide it won't kill you but
you wish you were dead
you might have to live underground or
maybe even underwater
in avatar The Way of the water you'll
dive under the waters of Pandora but if
this planet existed the water could kill
you
that's because that water would likely
be highly acidic thanks to the high
carbon dioxide levels in the atmosphere
it could be so bad it would dissolve all
sea life that has shells
yeah and that would severely affect the
food chain
even worse one dip in these Waters could
burn your skin off
you'd need to make sure that protection
suit was waterproof
but if you set up your life in the ocean
well you'd miss the beauty above the
surface
since Pandora and its gas giant are
tidally locked polyphemus would always
be visible in the sky
you would watch Alpha Centauri a rise
and set just as our sun does but
polyphemus would never leave your sight
if you were on Pandora's right side The
Other Side of the Moon would never get
this magnificent View
this comes with some trade-offs like
you'd have a hard time falling asleep
the Alpha Centauri star system Pandora
is located in has not just one not two
but Three Sons
Pandora would orbit around Alpha
Centauri a but another star Alpha
Centauri B would also be sending a lot
of light Pandora's way
it burns 2300 times as bright as the
full moon on Earth
and you wouldn't even be able to watch
Netflix during your sleepless nights
standard Electronics wouldn't last long
in this environment not with all that
radiation and electrical interference
you'd need space marine grade technology
to survive in this world
at least there would be enough animals
and plants for you to Feast on only I'd
recommend running chemical tests for
heavy metals and strong acids before you
eat anything
undetected toxins could destroy your
kidneys and liver
and there might be an unexpected side
effect
if you ate too much glowing food you
might become bioluminescent
Pandora would be a world of incredible
species and extreme wildlife
hey soon enough you might be taming an
ecron for the commute around your
strange and lethal home
uh but maybe you should think about
settling on a different exoplanet
what if we relocated every human to
Proxima B
well fire up the thrusters because
that's a story
for another
what if